so how can you say that's not a crisis
it doesn't matter what you call it it is
an enormous challenge
it is something that is front and center
for the president
oh the white house refuses to
acknowledge the crisis on our southern
border gop members know
of congress are taking it upon
themselves to see what is actually
happening with the delegation set to
visit
texas on monday our next guest is part
of that delegation florida gop
congressman carlos jimenez
congressman thank you for joining us
this morning so tell us why you're
headed to the border on monday
well we're heading to the border to see
for ourselves what's going on and also
to talk to
our federal agents to uh to get a better
idea of what actually is happening we
think that there is a crisis at the
border
of of uh joe biden president biden's uh
making you know we
my my fellow republican colleague john
cotko caught
disorder at the border due to executive
order and i think he is absolutely right
this uh this was a crisis that didn't
have to happen
created by the administration their
rhetoric their policy
their proposed legislation all of it is
causing this crisis at the border
congressman what are you looking for the
most in my apologies by the way for my
norwegian sounding pronunciation of your
name leading into this
that's okay but what do you when you go
to the border what are you focused on
as far as what's happening there uh well
you need to talk to the federal agents
and we need to talk also with
local law enforcement of what is
actually happening how many people are
crossing we already have some numbers
that say that the
the number of people crossing being
apprehended has almost tripled
uh from the same time period last year
the number of family units
that have been encountered went up from
a thousand
a month to six thousand now uh in uh
in february and it's just gonna get
worse and it doesn't matter that the
biden administration says don't come now
uh well when are we gonna come i mean
they should say don't come ever don't
break the law
uh they should have never reinstituted
catch and release they should have never
they should have never broken the
the agreements that they have with
mexico and other central american uh
countries that were keeping this you
know situation
uh manageable again a crisis of their
own making unnecessary crisis
putting americans lives in danger but
also putting the migrants
lives in danger because one of the few
things that people don't understand is
migrants lose their lives coming here
last year
in 2019 which is the last time we had
some stats 300 migrants at the border
uh you know lost their lives we don't
know how many more countless lose their
lives on the trip
and also the the effects of human
trafficking especially on young girls
we we have some stats that say about 30
percent about 1 in 3
are raped during this transition all
this is a humanitarian crisis
a humanitarian crisis again
of the biden administration's own
creation well congressman we wish you
luck on your trip we'd love to talk to
you or your colleagues when you come
back and
hear what you saw on the real pleasure
thank you so much thank you sir all
right
thank you